[Music]
danny is going to start off this hour
in harrisonburg virginia hi danny how
are you
hi gentlemen i'm doing great i'm a
little star struck uh
dave i gotta say i've i've listened to
you for years and
started when i took financial peace
university and um
my buddies give me a hard time that
whenever we go out to get a bite or
something to say uh i don't know is that
papa dave approved oh
that's cold well we're honored to have
you sir how can we help today
all right so the condensed version i'm
wondering if i should buy a house
that i do not want so a little back
story
my wife and i have been looking for a
house for the past year um
financially we're doing we feel prepared
as much as we can be we're in
uh baby step four we have a good chunk
of change set down
there is just no inventory in our area
and i finally broke today when i got a
call that a house we put a really
competitive offer on
um it went uh above it went
uh no inspection it went guaranteed
their their offer price
um and so just feeling frustrated so i
don't know if
we should just keep waiting uh our
landlord is selling our
the house we live right now and so we're
gonna be um
kicked out in uh august so we're a
little worried you know do we
find a place to rent and pay more than
what a mortgage would be or do we settle
on a
on a townhome or something really small
that we just don't like
i just went through this yeah yeah i
know
so what's the answer no no what don't
buy a house you don't like
yeah don't do that because you're going
to wake up in
12 months or 24 months 12 hours 12 yeah
12.
i don't like this house oh wait i never
liked this house what the heck did i do
and you're gonna it's it's like trying
to date somebody that you know you don't
have a future with and you just think
i'm gonna
i'll change them i'll change them and
i'll grow to like
that bathroom's not gonna move in that
house it's still gonna be there it is
yeah
i hate this for you hey listen i just
went through this it was
brutal it's a frustrating experience in
the market right now and it really
really is
yeah so this is euros first home
correct and you're how old
uh i'm 28 my wife's 25. every time
i face something like this i read a
study like
gosh it probably 20 years ago and it
affects the
affected my decision making paradigm
ever since here's what the study said
said that people who build wealth and
become wealthy
make decisions based on how it's going
to affect them
10 20 30 years from now people who are
broke make decisions based on how it's
going to feel this weekend
yeah thank god it's friday oh god it's
monday
is what broke that's what broke people
say but rich people when they get ready
to buy a watch
they say can i wear this for 10 years
20 years can i get some
or when they get ready to buy they buy
high they buy expensive things sometimes
but they buy high
value things that last that's right poor
people buy
uh and broke people and i've been both
but broke people buy
stuff that looks good right now but
that's cheap is crap and falls apart
you know and so it's kind of the same
decision-making they thank god it's
friday oh god it's money i'm gonna blow
all my money on the weekend
because i'm a child and so uh
emotionally
so the way i back up on something like
you're looking at when i'm frustrated
and tired
and feel boxed out by the market
which is all the things you feel and
it's your first house and
ah man we're about to pay more in rent
we're going to move twice because i got
to go rent something then i'll find
something right after i rent something
and
all that then then you know uh you know
so what what this tells you when i i pan
back i go what's the best decision ten
years from now
don't buy a house you don't like and man
it's hard
especially with my wife saying i just i
wanna i need a home yeah i've got two
little kids running around
um it's real real hard to be patient
yeah talk to your landlord and go hey if
i pay you a couple hundred dollars more
a month
would you rent for me for six more
months yeah buy yourself a little time
that's right and um or go somewhere for
a weekend
just go on a quick little getaway do
something just to kind of clear the deck
wipe the
white erase the whiteboard and you got
to start over again this is the worst
possible time to feel like you're forced
in to buy something right
because the market's called bananas
meaning people have gone bananas
they're nuts yeah i mean they're like
running down the street and driving a
stake in the yard this one's mine you
know
it's crazy the way they're acting and
it's just a freaking house
yeah you can get you another one there's
one on every
corner but no don't don't settle
don't cheap out because if you buy some
kind of crappy something because that's
what's available in this market you know
what it's going to be when you get ready
to sell it
something that's crappy that's available
in a hard to sell market yeah that's
you're gonna get stuck
well and beyond that you tell me when
you buy an ugly house at a deal and you
know what it is when you get ready to
sell it an ugly house and a deal
well you tell yourself all these these
fantasies like we'll just move those
bathrooms we'll build an add-on garage
and get a
new roof none of that will happen and
you set yourself up for
so much disappointment when you're there
it's such a good discussion though and
that's why we're leaning on it a little
bit and giving giving a little bit more
time because
there's so much activity in the market
so many people are feeling this
listen if you feel like you're you're
the temperature on your forehead is
changing
that's called house fever it's back away
you know you need to go take a cold
shower
back away from the contract
you're about to overpay you're about to
buy something you're about to settle
for something you don't like and that's
everybody out there man you're just
you're just an example of everybody
that's walking around looking at houses
right now
uh the opportunity to overpay is
legitimate and yes moving
twice but you know
let me tell you 10 years from now you
won't even remember no you won't or
you'll remember how bad it was but 10
years later who cares
yeah we rented a house we sold our house
after bankruptcy
our kids were in these private schools
we moved to another county to get in
better schools and we rented
the first time i'd ever rented since i'd
owned okay and i
owned a thousand pieces of property by
then and gone broke right
now i'm a renter that kitchen in that
rental house it was a nice it was a big
old house it was a reasonably nice house
it was a great school system which was
the whole goal right and we cashed out
of our other house and cleared up the
rest of the last of our debt after
bankruptcy
paid off the stinking irs right but
to this day when i mention that street
name
my wife's face gets a cloud across it
and all she says
is that kitchen that kitchen that
kitchen
that nasty brown linoleum floor that
kitchen
that kitchen because i mean she hated
hey but she transferred to that house
she transferred
that husband to that kitchen so that's
actually good for you
that's that's good broke and we were in
that ketchup that's right that's right
you're right she hates it instead of
doing she kept kept the
ire on the correct item yes that's good
but
i mean that's 30 years ago man it hangs
with you and i bought a house
under pressure and i still did this day
of regret that i did that it's still an
ugly i put my family through it and i
bought an ugly house
it was still an ugly house when i got
ready to sell it i've done that i've
done it don't do it just take your time
brother
i know it's hard take a cold shower take
your time this is the ramsey show